someone stole Alan turing's grades and
was willing to give up their life to
keep them let's try to understand the
surprising reason why I didn't plan to
make any more videos about Alan Turing
but I came across a story that just blew
my mind I was actually on Wikipedia
reading for a different video when I saw
a photo of Alan turing's PhD diploma and
in the caption on the Wikipedia article
it said something like this is the
recently returned stolen document from
Alan Turing and I thought what do you
mean stolen well what's happened here
digging into the story more I found that
a whole bunch of Alan turing's documents
including his PhD diploma his school
grades and some of his medals have been
recently or just last month returned to
an Alan Turing archive at his old school
these were repatriated documents and had
been stolen nearly 40 years ago I've got
the court documents here of what exactly
you went down so I'm going to go through
the chronology of how this happened and
how they got the documents back and then
show you what those stolen documents
were these documents include his PhD
diploma and his school report cards but
also some photos and Medals of tourings
these seem like kind of unimportant
documents but actually to the woman who
stole them she said that she would
defend them with her life in fact that
these were her life and that these
documents were so important to her that
without them she didn't think life was
worth living it is a good outcome that
the documents are now back in the
archive that turing's mother donated
them to for other people to read and
look at and enjoy and study but for that
one person who wanted them this is a bit
of a heartbreaking story Alan Turing
attended the Sherborne School in England
from 1926 to 1931. before of course he
would go on to to do really great things
in mathematics including working on the
Enigma machine cracking codes but also
becoming a leader and thinking about the
ideas of artificial intelligence and
mathematical underpinnings of
computation after he tragically died in
1954 at just age 41 turing's mother
donated a lot of his things to the
Sherborne school they didn't have a lot
of security around their archives at the
time and in 1984 a young woman in her
early 20s came to visit the archives and
asked to look at anything they had about
Alan Turing she asked a staff member
from the school how often people came to
look at turing's archives and they told
her it didn't happen very often Turing
wasn't really that well known at this
time this is before they made the
imitation game a movie about him but to
this one woman she was really obsessed
with Turing and after hearing that not
many people were coming to look at these
materials she got the idea that maybe
they would be better off with her and
that they belonged with her when she
left the school unknown to the librarian
she took a box of materials with her the
school didn't have a very good catalog
of exactly what it had and didn't even
really notice anything was missing until
they got a letter from the woman saying
how sorry she was and she that she knew
it was wrong that it had been hard for
her to steal but that she would take
good care of the materials and one day
return them she even returned some
materials to the school but these don't
seem to have been Originals they
included some replica medals that she
seems to have bought elsewhere and
definitely not all of the things that
she took away with her the staff member
who showed her around thought she was a
little odd and is quoted in the court
document saying that he's familiar with
the eccentricities of Americans but got
the impression that she had a crush on
touring now this woman was American and
she took her stolen documents back with
her to America the Sherborne School
figured they probably weren't going to
see these documents again they were just
hoping that maybe one day she would
return the rest of them now This Woman's
name was Julia schwinghamer but in 1988
a few years after the theft she actually
changed her name to Julia Turing
representing How Deeply she was enamored
with Alan Turing she saw him as kind of
a father figure or even a husband
despite the fact that he died seven
years before she was even born she never
met him and wasn't related to him at all
the best article that I found about this
story was one written by Chris Walker in
which he shows a lot of empathy for
Julia and why she was driven to want to
steal things from the archive rather
than just pinning her as a criminal it
turns out that she had a really rough
upbringing she was abandoned by her
parents Spencer time in foster care
before returning back to her biological
mum but never feeling at home she didn't
know how to read but one day watched the
movie Space Odyssey and was really taken
by the character of Hal 9000 the
computer on board in the movie that
seems a bit like a sentient machine as a
young girl this movie interested her so
much that she did something she'd never
done before and that was to go to a
library there she asked a librarian if
they had any books about machines that
could talk the librarian gave her a
bunch of books about Computing but for a
girl who didn't know how to read these
were a bit too hard to digest one of the
books though contained a photograph of
Alan Turing and she says that as soon as
she opened it to this page she was
overwhelmed with a sense of familiarity
looking at the photo that she checked
out that book and just had it open to
that photo page for the entire length of
the loan and then renewed it Julia
actually credits Alan Turing with saving
her life that the inspiration she got
from him dictated a lot of what she
pursued and was able to do with her life
she took up running because she heard
that Alan Turing had also been a good
runner and she actually went on to
compete at a really high level in
athletics for someone who didn't have
any adult Role Models growing up Julia
really found a sense of inspiration and
motivation in Alan Turing despite having
never met him her family were aware of
the succession and teased her a bit
about it and actually the next twist in
the story comes in 1988 when Julia was
having a fight with her sister Carol as
a way to get back at Julia what Carol
did was to round up some of the
materials that she could find that Julia
had on touring and took them to the
police station she must have known that
Julia had probably stolen them the
police station received him and sent
them back to the Sherborne school it
wasn't all of the materials though Julia
still had some of them hidden in her
house but for her she was heartbroken to
know that the PHD diploma was one of the
materials that had been returned this
next part is quite unbelievable but she
wrote to sherborne's school begging and
pleading them to let her keep the PHD
diploma she writes I am extremely
worried about the fate of Ellen's PhD it
means everything to me I place my very
life on it she even writes that as I
have written in my diary I will take my
life if Ellen's PhD cannot be returned I
have protected it with my life in the
past I have given up much for its safety
and will do so again if necessary and
this is the unbelievable part over a few
letters Julia is begging the Sherborne
school to let her have the diploma back
and they agreed or I shouldn't say they
agreed actually it was just that one
staff member who was receiving these
letters the same guy who showed Julia
around the archives on the day that she
stole them I think that he really did
feel empathy for Julia and probably
thought the PHD was best placed in her
hands it's not a decision he should have
made on his own he definitely should
have consulted the other Librarians all
of the school itself but he actually
sent the PHD diploma back to Julia she
happily kept possession of the diploma
and several other documents that she
hadn't told anyone about for a few more
decades until it all unraveled in 2018.
that year Julia contacted the University
of Colorado claiming to be a family
member of Alan Turing and offering to
loan them some of alunteering's
documents for display she'd been
inspired to do this because of the
growing interest in Alan Turing around
the world and she thought that some
people might like to see these documents
that's true although they weren't
appears to be loaning out the University
of Colorado were instantly a little
suspicious and they actually met with
Julia in person and looked at a bunch of
the documents she had they researched
some of those documents and contacted
the Sherborne school who told them that
a bunch of documents had been stolen in
the 1980s the university passed this
information on to authorities who issued
a search warrant for Julia's home where
they found heaps more materials more
than she'd even been willing to lend out
the police officers doing the search
actually asked Julia to help them look
for the items listed on the search
warrant she agreed and pretended to look
for stuff but appeared distracted they
noticed that she kept looking towards
the bathroom so they asked her to step
outside and wait for them to continue
the search and then they went back into
the bathroom and did a second look there
they found that a part of the wall was
actually removable and behind that it
led to a gap under the stairs and there
they found an old leather briefcase in
that briefcase was a bunch more
materials belonging to Sherborne school
there was a handwritten note from
turing's mother and even a handwritten
note from the King apologizing for not
being able to Award turing's Medal in
person because he'd been sick the
estimated value of all the stolen
materials is around thirty eight
thousand dollars and as of last month
these were returned to the Sherborne
school who have kindly made many of them
publicly available on the school website
years ago I made a video about Alan
turing's grades but those were just the
ones available at the time it's finally
time for a part two of that video
looking at the rest of Alan turing's
grades now that we have a complete
picture of what his time was like at
school this first report card is from
1924 when Ellen was around 12. his Latin
teacher said that his work was spoiled
by bad writing and lack of neatness this
is a common theme throughout his report
cards in French he was top of the class
probably because his parents had been
living in France and in math he wasn't
top of the class in fact he was fourth
out of eight students it says an
excellent terms work he has absorbed 90
percent of what he has been taught and
coming only fourth out of eight in the
class kind of means nothing especially
at an early age to go on and Achieve
great things in mathematics you don't
have to have always been top of the
class overall very good work but his
writing has got as bad as ever again now
in 1926 when he's 14 turing's history
teacher says that he comes out with
surprising information at times but has
on the whole worked very well his Latin
teacher describes him as delightfully
ingenious and unspoiled he shows
distinct promise in mathematics this
time he ranks fifth with the teacher
saying that he has done very well and
has steady application is much to be
commended his Headmaster describes him
as original a very interesting character
honestly that's how many people would
describe Alan Turing today looking back
at his achievements the next term that
same Headmaster said he appears
self-contained and is apt to be solitary
this is not due to moroseness but simply
I think to a shy disposition in math
again he is fifth very good work his
work is thoughtful and promising the
remark from the history teacher stings a
little bit it says tries hard but has
very little knowledge this next one from
when he was aged 15 is kind of funny his
English teacher absolutely rips into him
it seems like perhaps they didn't get
along that well the teacher says I can
forgive his writing though it is the
worst I have ever seen I am squinting to
make out the next sentence I think it
says I try now to tolerate his hand
right writing an executed and
something Dirty Work inconsistency
something something
he's being ripped into about how bad his
handwriting is but the ironic thing is
that I can't read this comment from the
teacher because I can't read this
handwriting I can make out this part the
teacher says but I cannot forgive the
stupidity of his attitude towards name
discussion on the New Testament with a
note he has been caught doing algebra
during Divinity lesson maybe this is
when Tyrion got truly interested in
mathematics it's funny to me to see a
report growling a student for doing
algebra during another class but maybe
deterring the algebra was truly more
enjoyable than the Divinity lesson seems
like he also ranked last in that class
or close to it this same year in
mathematics he has risen to first in the
class the teacher said he's a very
interesting boy to take he is full of
ideas in science they say he is of
course a very promising boy but is
frequently untidy both in written and
experimental work this must be cured of
course people thinking they could cure
Alan Turing of supposed ailments caused
him much pain throughout his life when
he was chemically castrated for being
gay this is different but shows a bit of
the culture at the time that anything
different was something to be cured and
tearing might have been used to hearing
that people considered things he did and
who he was to be wrong by the time he's
18 it seems that Turing was able to
improve his handwriting or at least
satisfy the teachers one teacher says
that he continues to be a genius
intellect in physics and the same
English teacher that ripped into him a
few years ago seems to be in a better
mood saying that he has intelligent work
this is his final school report card
upon leaving Sherborne school and by now
he has has been awarded a scholarship to
attend King's College in Cambridge the
Headmaster writes that he is a gifted
and distinguished boy whose future
career we shall watch with much interest
I have found him Pleasant and friendly
and they believe he has Justified his
appointment as a school prefect on the
screen now you'll see a link to my
previous video going through more of his
grades thank you for watching this video
and thank you to my patreon supporters
for making it possible a special shout
out to today's patreon cat of the day
marchan
foreign